but it seems fears of a per tracted
trade wall between US and China are
receding on there are reports that talks
are underway behind the scenes to avert
the damaging slow showdown so are we out
of the trade wall woods and where next
four markets are with me now is an
Barrie managing director at Cornell
Capital having spent ten years at
Goldman Sachs in New York and good to
see ya
did the markets overreact last week I
mean one point four trillion dollars was
wiped from the value of the S&P 500 all
over fifteen billion dollars worth of
tariffs on US goods I hate the
implications though for that one
particular policy sweep that was coming
out or enormous if you think about the
interconnectivity of global trade this
wasn't just about the implications for
either the US or China but also much
more broadly both across Asia and across
you know other parts of the North
American trade association but yet some
would say well hang on if America and
China stop buying as much from each
other they'll simply have to substitute
that with goods from other people and
whilst it may cost them a bit more
overall trade global isn't that much
affected I think it's just given that
connectivity it's more complicated so
for example if we look at the last bout
of trade announcement that came out
which was the tariffs on steel and
animal aluminium that were announced you
can see today Canada's come out and
announce anti-dumping trading rules in
Canada so it isn't just the u.s. in
isolation that's causing changes and
other in other countries trade policies
but you can see the repercussions are
much broader so how much substance how
much credence you giving to these
reports that there's a lot of talk going
on behind the scenes in that between the
US and China well it's definitely a big
announcement to have made if that wasn't
the case I think that certainly if you
look at both the US and the China's
national self-interest it makes a lot of
sense for them to try to come to an
agreement for example when the u.s. came
out and announced potential tariffs but
with very little detail and up to fifty
billion dollars worth of product China
came out with a very targeted response
which included going after for example
some farm products from the US now that
would come out at a time when US farming
comes with the lowest they've been in a
decade so the incentive really is there
to come to agree on all places are voted
for Donald Trump of course these big
farming communities yeah absolute in the
heartland interestingly though Trump's
popularity rating has gone up seven
percent during the last month it
suggests a met
the ordinary American voters actually
quite like what he's done here which op
is very clear during election campaign
that he was very much running on an
America first platform and he's also
been clear in his speech since then that
one of the pillars of national security
will be trade quote-unquote on a
reciprocal and fair basis so from that
perspective he can be seen to being
delivering on that that Heartland
promise but the jury's out on the detail
still right I mean do you think the
terrace that he's introduced that trumps
introduced is that more about gaining
leverage in trade talks rather than
being a straightforward blunt
protectionist measure as some have
suggested well again if you look back at
what's happened on the steel and
aluminium tariffs you've seen caveats to
these bold statements coming pretty
quickly so Canada and Mexico were very
quickly given carve outs and exemptions
I think the expectation here is you
might see something of the same and the
EU as well
I mean you as well and I mean
particularly again as Trump has tied
tariffs to national security and
thinking about the interplay with allies
from a military perspective you know the
EU is a big friend to United States
you'd imagine some incentive that for
collaboration what about the markets in
general they're not I mean obviously we
had this amazing bounce back overnights
on Wall Street's all that by is it
justified well the dip that it's coming
off the back of was enormous so
yesterday was the biggest one-day move
upwards since the financial crisis but
off the back of the biggest two-week dip
you've seen in the last two years so the
volatility that I think we're seeing is
probably likely to continue others
unfolds it's worth pointing out we also
I mean we're at the end of the month or
at the end of the call so you often see
a bit of books growing I mentioned it
just now with the FX markets you see
that especially where that could is done
you you do and I think also there's a
lot of domestic policy that's coming out
affecting the US equity market too we
saw the interest rate edict come out
folks are still very much got their eyes
on inflation so trade isn't alone is not
the only thing that the markets watching
right now all right and Barry from
Cornell Capital great is here thanks
that your enemy